today's episode of the y-files is
brought to you by established titles
Ed and Lorraine Warren are maybe the
most famous paranormal investigators in
history they've worked on more than 10
000 cases some of which have been made
into books and movies The Conjuring
films are based on the work of the
warrants today we'll look at a few of
their scariest most disturbing cases so
turn off the lights and put the little
ones to bed it's gonna get spooky
December 1975 Amityville New York
what we're jumping right in with
Amityville I don't know about this you
know I don't like to be scared yeah I
know but we took a vote on the channel
and most people said they wanted scary
stories well yeah well they should be
the ones to clean my bowl after myself
okay that's enough I'm just saying
they're gonna be consequences December
1975 Amityville New York George and
Kathleen Lutz were house hunting though
the asking price of 112 Ocean Avenue in
Amityville was higher than their budget
at eighteen thousand dollars it was a
steal soon the lutzes Learned why a year
earlier in the house 23 year old Ronald
defeo Jr also known as Butch snapped on
November 13th at 3 15 a.m he slowly and
systematically went bedroom to bedroom
and murdered his entire family Butch
defeo's father mother two sisters and
two brothers were all shot with a 35
caliber rifle while they slept Butch
claimed he heard voices urging him to
kill his attorney William Weber tried
the insanity defense but it didn't work
in November 1975 which was sentenced to
six consecutive life sentences one month
later George and Kathleen Lutz along
with their three children moved in to
the defeo house the lutzes weren't that
religious but they asked the local
priest to bless the house while the
family was unpacking father pecoraro was
in an upstairs room praying as soon as
he splashed holy water the priest heard
a voice that said get out father
pecoraro didn't tell the lutzes
specifically what happened but he warned
them not to use that second floor room
for a bedroom and stay out of the room
altogether if they could did they stay
out they wish they did
like this
within a few days the Lutz has noticed
strange activity at first it was just
sounds doors slamming footsteps strange
mumbling then the house wouldn't get
warm no matter how high they turned up
the heat so they kept the fire going day
and night George sometimes saw demonic
faces in the fire Missy Lutz then five
years old started talking about an
imaginary friend named Jody green slime
was found oozing from the walls and
through keyholes doors and windows were
found suddenly damaged one night George
saw his wife Kathy transform into an old
woman who looked like a witch he saw
hoof prince in the snow leading into
their house George would wake up at 3 15
every morning the same time the defeo
family was killed one night he heard his
children's bed slamming up and down on
the floor but he couldn't do anything
about it because he was paralyzed in bed
by an unseen Force later that night he
saw his wife levitating and moving
across the bed the next morning after
only 28 days the lutzes had enough they
left the Amityville house and all their
belongings and moved in with friends and
that's when they brought in the Warrens
on March 6th Ed and Lorraine Warren
conducted a seance in the house with
several psychics Lorraine a clairvoyant
said she encountered Butch's Spirit
during the Seance and felt what she
described as an overwhelming feeling of
horrible depression the inhuman the
Diabolical are attracted to where
tragedies occur
just like a moth would be attracted to a
light
and when the Lutz family moved in 13
months after these murders
they were still using some of the
furniture that was in there Ed Warren
said the house was possessed by demons
the psychic team took a series of time
lapse photos of the upstairs Landing
none of the photographs showed anything
out of the ordinary except one keep in
mind that bush defeo's little brother
John was only nine years old on the
night he was killed the photo shows
peering out from one of the bedrooms a
little boy with glowing eyes after the
luxes moved out of the house things
returned to normal two years later they
would tell their story to author Jay
Anson who released the book The
Amityville Horror the book was an
instant sensation selling over 6 million
copies the story gained even more
notoriety in 1979 when the movie
Amityville Horror hit theaters since
then 12 books at a total of 28 films
have been inspired by the story today
the Amityville house looks much like it
did in the 70s after all this time it's
still one of the most famous and
frightening houses in the country and
maybe the world
[Music]
foreign
1970 Donna a nursing student received a
gift from her mother for her 20th
birthday a Raggedy Ann doll Donna loved
the doll and took it back to her house
that she shared with another young nurse
named Angie the doll's place in the
house was sitting up on the couch but
Donna and Angie noticed the doll would
be found in different rooms Donna would
set her on the living room couch before
she left work she'd come home and the
doll was in her room with the door shut
then Donna and Angie started finding
notes around the apartment they were
written in child's handwriting and said
help me and the notes were written on
parchment paper that they didn't have in
the house one day they came home and the
doll had moved again but this time it
had a sticky red substance on its hands
that appeared to be blood within a few
hours the red substance was gone Angie's
boyfriend Lou said the doll gave him a
creepy feeling and told him to get rid
of it they wouldn't that night while Lou
was sleeping he heard a noise in the
room like someone was walking around
then he felt something on the bed he
looked up and said the dawn was quickly
crawling on the bed on his body he went
to yell but the doll covered his mouth
and choked him until he passed out the
next morning he tried to convince
himself that it was all a dream but he
couldn't shake it Donna and Angie didn't
know what to do they felt like they were
going crazy they contacted a local
medium for help the medium held a seance
and told the women that the doll was
possessed by a seven-year-old girl named
Annabelle Higgins they later found out
that the body of the young girl was
found on the property years earlier
before their apartment building was
built the medium told the girls that the
doll who they now called Annabelle just
wanted someone to play with and someone
to love and care for her Annabelle asked
permission to stay in the doll and live
with the young nurses the young nurses
said no they got rid of the doll d end
nope they kept it I was afraid he'd say
that they felt bad for Annabelle and
agreed to let her stay in the doll and
they would take care of her that turned
out to be a terrible mistake
after the medium left Angie and Donna
explain the story to Lou to try to get
him to come around he said the story
just made it worse get rid of the doll
they still said no over the next days
and weeks the strange activities
continued sounds in the middle of the
night Annabelle moving from room to room
and now the notes changed from help me
to help Lou one day Lou was helping
Donna and Angie pack for a road trip he
saw that Annabelle looked like she was
just thrown onto the floor so he went
over to pick her up and then he felt a
sharp pain in his chest he looked down
and saw blood seeping through his shirt
underneath he had seven long bloody
scratches in the shape of the mark of
the beast within two days the Marx
disappeared like they were never there
maybe the Beast uses Neosporin please no
one-liners when I'm trying to be scary
I'm just finally Angie and Donna agreed
to do something they call the church and
explained what was happening the church
reached out to Ed and Lorraine Warren Ed
Warren was the only lay person
recognized by the church as a
demonologist the Warrens arrived and
spoke to the young women at length and
Lorraine explained that the doll was not
possessed by a little girl but possessed
by a demon and now that the demon was
invited to live there it would try to
find a human host the Warrens agreed to
take the doll and put it somewhere the
demon couldn't escape so Ed put
Annabelle in the back seat of the car he
suggested that they don't take freeways
home and he was right several times on
the drive the car tried to run itself
off the road and the brakes would give
out come back and then give out again Ed
turned around and splashed holy water on
Annabelle and after that the car worked
fine even after they got Annabelle home
it continued to torment and terrorize it
would move around the house and at some
point Ed found the doll levitating near
his desk one day a young priest was
visiting and saw Annabelle he mocked the
all and said you're just a doll you
can't hurt anyone bad move
well on his way home his brakes gave out
and the priest was killed several people
who mocked Annabelle ended up in car
wrecks soon after finally the Warrens
put Annabelle in a glass case and on the
case is a note that ominously says
positively do not open today Annabelle
still sits in her glass case at the
occult Museum in the Warren's house
ghost hunters mediums and psychics still
visit Annabelle to this day all report
feeling a dark negative energy coming
from the doll but nobody opens the case
and everyone treats her with respect
[Music]
foreign
was released in 2013 it was praised not
just for being extremely scary but for
feeling like a true story that's because
it is in January 1971 the Perrin family
moved into an old farmhouse in
Harrisville Rhode Island almost
immediately Carolyn Roger and their Five
Daughters saw strange things happening
like most of these stories the first
activity was so small that it would go
unnoticed like things being out of place
Carolyn would notice that her broom
would never be in the same place she
left it then the noises started loud
thuds footsteps and the sounds of people
moving around in the kitchen one day
Carolyn found muddy Footprints and small
piles of dirt on her freshly washed
kitchen floor then the girls started
seeing spirits around the house most of
the spirits ignored the girls but a few
didn't and all those Spirits were angry
eight-year-old Cindy Perrin kept hearing
a voice whispering in her bedroom it
said there are seven dead soldiers in
the walls one day Carolyn walked into
the kitchen and saw a man standing there
just leaning against the wall she said
he was wearing old-time clothes which
makes sense the house was built in 1736
ghosts also appeared sitting at their
dining room table and some seem to be
aware that the parents were there the
ghosts pointed at them and then vanished
other ghosts ignored them before
disappearing so Carolyn researched the
history of the house and discovered it
had been in the Arnold Family for
Generations she thought the man she saw
in the kitchen was John Arnold Carolyn
learned there had been at least eight
deaths on the property some of them
gruesome a few of them children
foreign
learned that the primary evil force was
the spirit of a woman named Bathsheba
Sherman who lived in the house in the
mid 19th century she was not a nice lady
she had a reputation for beating and
starving the hired help while her
husband Judson farmed the land she took
care of the house Bathsheba had four
children three of whom died very young
local Legend claims Bathsheba was a
witch because an infant while in her
care mysteriously died the cause of
death was determined to be a sowing
needle that impaled the baby's skull
locals believed that this was an
offering to the devil but bathsheva was
never convicted of any wrongdoing when
Bathsheba died Legend says she turned to
stone the parents said that at 5 15
every morning there would be the smell
of rotten flesh in the house and the air
would become terribly cold and the heat
wouldn't work one especially scary night
Roger perrin's bed was lifted into the
air and dropped soon Carolyn started
feeling like Bathsheba was trying to
make her kill her children the way
Bathsheba killed hers that's when the
parents called Ed Lorraine Warren for
help the Warren spent a few hours
walking the house and talking to the
parents then they performed a seance
against Roger parents wishes here's
Roger in his own words the Warrens came
over and they did the uh the Seance in
the house
it was that was not a good thing I was
against it but they did it anyway
and three to five minutes into the
Seance and my wife got all the whole
body would went out of shape and
extorted and it was it was like an extra
somebody was squeezing her and her chair
cut off of the floor and came right into
me into the Next Room
and I tried to to help her you know she
she was completely out of this world at
that point speaking crazy words
and I tried to help her at that point
Roger had seen enough he actually
punched Ed in the mouth and threw the
Warrens out of the house and told him
never to return but soon after the
Seance The Haunting stopped
[Music]
August 1977 Enfield North London this is
considered one of the events that proves
the existence of poltergeists Peggy
Hodgson had just put her children to bed
when she heard the sound of a chair
being dragged across the bedroom floor
Peggy went into the room and her
daughters were under their blankets
terrified the chair was upside down on
the floor and they said they didn't do
it they said the chair moved on its own
so Peggy turned out the lights and then
heard the sound of scraping when she
turned the lights back on she saw a
dresser slide 18 inches across the floor
Peggy wasn't quite sure what was
happening she tried to push the dresser
back into place but it wouldn't budge
Peggy called her neighbors over to make
sure she wasn't going crazy the
neighbors also heard the sounds Peggy
finally called the police one of the
responding officers said she heard
knocking or tapping and saw the chair
wobble then she saw the chair slide
across the floor about three feet this
is in the official police report but the
police said there's no crime so there's
nothing they can do after a couple of
months ever everyone in the house was
sleeping in the same room and then the
activity got worse voices of an old man
started coming from Janet and her lips
weren't moving this voice is coming from
an 11 year old girl
I've actually got something to say
something yeah I'd like to know how you
make this noise without bashing Janet's
vocal cords to pieces for half a minute
I'd get a sore throat there's chases
here Peggy didn't know where to turn so
she went to the media soon reporters and
paranormal investigators descended on
the family performing test after test
there are photos of Janet being
levitated out of bed there's video of
knocking sounds responding to questions
from mediums guy Playfair was a writer
and parapsychologist with the society
for psychical research he spent a great
deal of time with the family he
witnessed a lot of poltergeist activity
with his own eyes by 1978 the Enfield
Poltergeist attracted the attention of
Ed and Lorraine Warren at this point in
time the Warrens were icons in
paranormal research they flew to London
to investigate Ed Warren was convinced
there was a demonic presence The Voice
coming from Janet said its name was Bill
and that he lived and died in the house
the voice said that he had died of a
brain hemorrhage while sitting in a
chair Bill's son confirmed all of that
was true
some months later gross was contacted by
Terry Wilkins whose father bill was
buried in a nearby cemetery and had
lived at the house before the hodgsons
moved in
I had an average
astonishingly The Voice had described
the precise circumstances of Bill
Wilkins death
but it describes exactly that's exactly
what happened he died in this year down
in the living room in all there were
more than 30 Witnesses who saw furniture
moving objects flying around cold
breezes physical assaults pools of water
appearing on the floor graffiti and
matches spontaneously igniting the
Enfield Poltergeist tortured Peggy Janet
and the entire family for 18 months it
almost ruined their lives then as
quickly as it started
it stopped
[Music]
because snedekers lived in Upstate New
York but found themselves traveling to
Connecticut a lot Phillip eldest son of
Carmen and Allen snedeker had Hodgkin's
lymphoma and his hospital was in
Connecticut in 1986 Carmen and Allen had
had enough of the commute and decided to
rent something near the Yukon hospital
they packed up their four children and
two of their nieces and moved to a
spacious duplex on a quiet street in
Southington Connecticut as soon as they
moved in Allen began Renovations on the
basement to make a bedroom for Philip
while cleaning out some rusty tools and
other basement junk he found an old
piece of equipment he didn't recognize
it looked like a pump with a couple of
old tubes coming out of it turns out it
was embalming equipment
corpses no Allen kept renovating he
found two rooms one was the embalming
room complete with equipment and Rusty
floor drains the other room was a casket
display room the snedeker is now
realized why the rent was so low on such
a big house it used to be a funeral home
the hallahan funeral home to be exact
Philip's bedroom would be the former
casket room and almost immediately he
heard strange sounds and voices he saw
dark figures moving in the shadows he
saw a man with white hair and a
pinstripe suit one night he saw bodies
stacked up against the wall Philip was
so frightened he asked to sleep in the
hospital which his parents didn't allow
Carmen thought Philip was hallucinating
because of his cancer medication but
then everyone started seeing and hearing
things how many bodies passed through
that house over the years well it was a
funeral home for a few decades so
thousands of bodies yeah nope the
snedekers knew they had ghosts at first
the ghost just made sounds and moved
things around the house they would find
light bulbs unscrewed from their sockets
but still somehow emitted light an altar
the house was the smell of feces and
Decay it became unbearable the entire
family was terrified and just when they
couldn't take it anymore the ghosts
became violent
[Music]
what began as strange sounds smells and
visions of spirits soon became much more
the spirits became physically violent
one night both Carmen and her niece
Tammy had a terrifying encounter Carmen
woke up and felt a dark energy around
her she couldn't see anything but she
felt cold hands reaching under her
pajamas and grabbing at her underwear
then she heard an evil laugh Carmen's
niece had the same exact encounter but
she was whoa what was that
save here we'll get demonetized again oh
we don't want that no we don't so we'll
censor it and the grown-ups out there
can fill in the blanks good thinking
eventually both Carmen and her husband
Alan worked there by The Entity multiple
times one night Carmen finally saw the
ghosts one had long white hair and white
eyes the other had black hair and black
eyes that's when they called Ed and
Lorraine Warren the Warrens and their
team of investigators spent nine weeks
in the snedeker house and during that
time they saw everything the snedekers
reported members of the team were pushed
slapped even knocked to the ground Ed
and Lorraine searched the history of the
home they discovered that one of the
morticians who worked there was a
necrophiliac definition but he had a
thing for corpses worst hobby ever Ed
said that the spirit infused the home
with evil the Warrens felt that an
exorcism would work and after the house
was cleansed the snedekers moved out
then the Warrens hired author Ray Garden
to document everything that happened in
the house the documentation of these
events became the book in a dark place
the story of a true haunting the
snedeker case was also made into the
movie The Haunting in Connecticut
released in 2009 since the snedeker's
moved out nobody has reported anything
strange in the house since and the owner
makes sure to tell all renters that it
was once a funeral home and that the
renter should keep that in mind before
they sign the lease
Ed and Lorraine Warren are possibly the
most successful paranormal investigators
in history they've written or
contributed to at least 30 books about
their cases their work has inspired the
movies in The Conjuring Universe a film
franchise worth over two billion dollars
but the Warrens have their detractors
with many Skeptics calling them outright
frauds and grifters so what's the truth
well Ed and Lorraine Warren met when
they were 16 years old at a local movie
theater their conversation soon moved to
the Paranormal Ed believes he grew up in
a haunted house and Lorraine claimed to
be Clairvoyant they were married when
they were 19 when Ed was on leave from
the army they soon made their livings as
artists they would go to houses that
they believed were haunted paint them
and then try to sell the painting to the
owner oof that's a rough racket it was
so Ed supplemented their income by
driving a bus though they were making a
name for themselves locally as
paranormal investigators their
breakthrough came in 1979 with the
Amityville Horror case when the Warrens
arrived in Amityville they brought an
entire film crew with them unfortunately
the film crew didn't capture anything
except for the moanings of a few
psychics yeah
right the ghost boy on top of the stairs
yeah that's a creepy photo but it's
actually a photograph of Paul Barts oh
the more cop no Paul Bartz was one of
the investigators he doesn't have
glowing eyes that's just light
reflecting off his glasses the cameras
snapped a picture of him when he was
setting up some equipment but the photo
became so famous that nobody bothered to
refute it now the Lutz did call Father
pecoraro to bless the house which he did
he also said there was nothing strange
about the house it was a peaceful and
lovely home other parts of the story are
also a little sketchy the lutzes
couldn't have seen hoof prints in the
snow because there was no snow at that
time and all the damage that supposedly
happened to the house didn't doors
windows the entire house was in perfect
shape when they moved in and when they
left the Amityville story was actually
created by Butch defeo's lawyer William
Weber and the Lott's family one night
they were discussing a way to help each
other Weber wanted an insanity verdict
for Butch defeo he was also working on a
book deal the lutzes were struggling
dealing financially and they like the
sound of a book deal Weber said that
after four bottles of wine their meeting
turned into a creative writing session
but the lutzes didn't like their cut of
Weber's book deal author Jay Anson
offered the Lutz's 50 50. that they
liked and with millions of books selling
like crazy and movie offers coming at
them it was in their financial interest
to stick with the story The Amityville
Horror Story is definitely debunked the
next case we talked about was Annabelle
the possessed doll this story is easier
to track it's basically a retelling beat
for Beat of The Twilight Zone episode
living doll which aired in 1963 on CBS
here's the synopsis Eric Streeter is
upset when his wife comes home with her
daughter Christy having bought her yet
another doll Christy loves her new
talking Tina doll but her stepfather
takes an immediate dislike to it anytime
he is alone with the doll it spouts
abusive comments to the effect that it
hates him and that it's going to kill
him my name is straight out and I'm
going to get rid of you
it's a great episode and every Twilight
Zone fan knows it Ed and Lorraine were
apparently fans of the show too and
co-opted the story still not convinced
the mother's name in The Twilight Zone
episode was Annabelle we can call that
one debunked how about Bathsheba Sherman
the witch that tormented the parents as
portrayed in The Conjuring when The
Conjuring was released in 2013 the owner
of the house at the time Norma Sutcliffe
was tortured by the witch no buy movie
fans she released a video that year
complaining about how her property was
descended upon by horror fans at all
hours day or night there would be people
in her yard exploring the barn on her
property and even sticking cameras and
phones through her window she was
Furious she even sued Warner Brothers
over this in her video Norma goes on to
debunk basically the whole story
Bathsheba was a real person but that's
about all the story gets right she never
lived in that house never killed anyone
by all accounts she was is a lovely
woman she died peacefully at the age of
73. so a very little
very little none actually her last act
before she died was to provide for her
grandchildren's education Norma lived in
that house for years she said nothing
strange happened in the house before or
since now maybe Norma Sutcliffe just got
lucky and the house was haunted when the
parents were there maybe they got a few
Juicy Book deals and a movie out of the
story so they said and continued to say
their story is true oh the parents
didn't reach out to Ed and Lorraine
Warren for help the Warrens just showed
up that's something they did a lot they
finally left when Mr Perrin punched Ed
in the mouth so Bathsheba Sherman and
The Conjuring debunked the snedeker's
case is another one that doesn't make
the Warrens look good Ray Garden the
author that Ed Warren hired really
struggled writing the book it was
difficult with the family involved they
were going through some serious problems
like alcoholism and drug addiction they
could not keep their story straight and
it became very frustrated it's hard
writing a non-fiction book when all the
people involved are telling you
different stories when Garten told Ed
Warren about this Ed said oh they're
crazy only crazy people call us so
Garden asked what he's supposed to do
about the book Ed says use what works
and just make the rest up just make it
scary and this was not the first time Ed
Warren hired a horror writer for help
not a journalist not a biographer a
horror fiction writer also what's not
widely reported is that Philip their son
with cancer was caught touching and
trying to rear his cousins he even got
pretty close once police took him to a
mental hospital where he was diagnosed
with schizophrenia and schizophrenia
could certainly explain why he was
seeing and hearing things yeah but it
wouldn't explain what everyone else was
no but the snedeker's lived in the house
for two years without an incident but
after they got behind on the rent and
their landlady had begun eviction
proceedings suddenly the house was
haunted also their story has a lot of
details that sound like the movie The
Entity which was popular and super scary
what's also not widely reported is that
the family dealt with alcoholism and
drug addiction which makes everything
worse in fact Ray Garden said that while
he was working on the book he never
actually saw Philip and the snedekers
never mentioned what kind of cancer he
had he did speak to Philip on the phone
and Philip told him that when he stayed
on his medication the ghost stopped then
Philip's mother quickly ended the call
Ray garden and some of the snedeker's
neighbors suspected the family might
have been using cancer as a cover story
for Phillips mental health problems and
drug addiction and despite their claims
they were fully aware that the house was
a funeral home and there was a tenant
living in the upstairs apartment who
never saw or heard anything the
snedeker's neighbors their landlady even
the person writing the book about the
case all said the story was made up this
one is safely debunked the Enfield
Poltergeist is a tricky one we know at
least some of the story was a hoax
because Janet admitted to it and the
kids were caught multiple times faking
so-called paranormal incidents and
people say the voice was coming from her
without her mouth moving but there's
plenty of video of her mouth moving the
photo of Janet levitating above the bed
looks a lot like her jumping off the bed
and that picture was taken with a motion
controlled camera in the girl's bedroom
so nobody else was in the room to
confirm what actually happened this was
another case where the movie exaggerates
the Warren's involvement again they just
showed up uninvited they stayed for a
few hours looked around and left the
following day Ed Warren did have a
chance to speak to guy Playfair the
investigator who spent the most time
with the family Ed told guy he could
make a lot of money from this case guy
wasn't interested but the Warrens wrote
it up anyway they cashed in and called
this another one of their 10 000 cases
except they didn't investigate 10 000
cases if they did one case a day without
a day off that would take them 27 years
so we caught Ed stretching the truth
again speaking of there is one true
horror story here his name is Ed Warren
foreign
Warner Brothers multi-film multi-billion
dollar Conjuring franchise follows Ed
and Lorraine Warren a devoutly religious
happily married couple who traveled the
world helping rid frightened families of
ghosts and demons
but just weeks after the release of the
first film in 2013 the studio learned
about allegations made against Ed Warren
according to Judith Penny Ed Warren
initiated a relationship with her when
she was only 15. she used to take his
bus and he developed feelings for her
and if that wasn't disturbing enough
soon Judith moved into the Warren's
house her relationship with Ed continued
for over 40 years and the rain knew all
of this Judith's bedroom was directly
across from the Warrens eventually they
built an apartment for her upstairs and
according to Judith Penny's sworn
testimony Ed would sleep downstairs
sometimes and upstairs sometimes their
marriage wasn't as perfect as it's been
portrayed due to the said Ed would often
beat Lorraine sometimes knocking her
unconscious she said she was worried he
might kill the rain one day Ed often
told Judith that she was the love of his
life and in 1978 she became pregnant she
had his baby nope but uh oh no she was
told a child would complicate the
Warren's business when attorney Jill
Smith was working through the Warren's
movie contract there was specific
language that she had never seen before
now it's not unusual for producers to
sign a non-disparagement clause when
adapting a true story nobody wants to
sell their story and then look bad but
this contract specifically said that the
movies could not depict an extramarital
affair relationships with minors and
some other specific things that I won't
get into here but suffice it to say the
descriptions were graphic now in the
Warren's defense they said Judith was a
girl they took in for charity and she
would watch the house when they were
traveling Judy and Tony sparra the
Warren's daughter and son-in-law say
they never saw any of the alleged
conduct the sparas believed Judith penny
is being manipulated though I don't know
for what purpose she's in her 70s
married and doesn't make any money from
the films the Warner Brothers did offer
her a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
for her life story hush money yup Judith
says she remained friendly with Ed until
his death in 2006 but despite her
fondness for him what he did was
Despicable and a crime what it all comes
down to is this no case that the Warrens
worked on was ever supported by any
evidence besides their word ed claimed
to have photos and video but those were
never produced I did see one video that
Ed spoke about the ghost called the Lady
in White
[Music]
now that's a pretty compelling video but
Judith Penny said Ed told her to put on
a white dress and walk around a cemetery
so she did now I'm not saying ghosts
aren't real and that the Warrens lied
about everything I am saying they lied
about some things and because of that we
have to question everything they say Ed
Warren was a self-proclaimed
demonologist he said that anyone who is
possessed by a demon he could find and
eradicate it I guess he would know Ed
Warren had a few Demons of his own
today's episode is brought to you by one
of the most unique sponsors we've ever
had established titles and that doesn't
sound like VPN software it's not huh
nice change of pace
established titles let you buy as little
as one square foot of land in Scotland
and this allows you to call yourself
Lord or Laird as they say or lady also
established titles plants a tree with
every order and is partnered with great
Charities like one tree planted
hold on what did you just say I could
buy land in Scotland and become a lord
yep you can even use the title on your
credit cards plane tickets online dating
profile yep so I want it well there's
more I want to tell you about this I
want it now
[Music]
that's my Lord package
I hear it
you're kidding me right
what is this I'm what is this my Lord if
you don't mind yeah you might be taking
this a little too
okay okay hang on I could
get okay
this certifies you as Lord hecklefish
Moriarty and uh this is the plot Number
of your land in Edelson Scotland and uh
they even sent us coordinates Google Map
[__] that I may survey my domain
oh this is pretty nice it is I can't
wait to get some surfs out there to work
the land for me and pay me tribute uh
you can't have any serves I shall be a
strict but fair Lord of these lands
myself will come to idolize me you can't
have serfs I could maybe have a few
safes you can't one surf no stop saying
surfs stop saying surfs my Lord all
right but check this out the first 200
people who purchase a title pack using
the promo code twf will get land right
near yours Kingdom Kinda Yeah I shall be
a strict but fair Lord to all who
purchase using promo code twf well you
won't be there Lord there'll be Lords
and Ladies of their own land but for now
but when I raise an Army in coconut land
I shall rule over them and they will
come to know me as a strict but fair
Lord you can't conquer their land then
maybe a marriage pact to strengthen the
kingdom I don't see how that shall be
truth my eldest son to the daughter of
one of the other Lords we will unite our
kingdoms and my blood shall rule these
lands for a thousand years is you have
an eldest son what do you think those
guppy support payments are for Heckle Jr
lives with his mother in Hackensack New
Jersey if you use code twf you'll get an
additional 10 off so go to
establishtitles.com twf you'll be Lord
of your own land you'll get your own
plot number and you get this cool frame
certificate this makes an amazing last
minute gift plus you'll be supporting a
great charity and helping out the
channel and you'll be joining my kingdom
right and that you will come to know me
as a strict yeah we got it before me get
bent it don't make me declare premenacta
ugh gross
[Laughter]
thanks so much for hanging out with me
today my name is AJ that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do us a favor and
like subscribe comment share I know it's
annoying to hear me ask that but it
really helps the channel and like most
topics we cover on the channel today's
topic was recommended by you if there's
a story you'd like to see or learn more
about go to the yfiles.com tips a
special thanks to our patrons who make
this channel possible you guys are the
best I couldn't do this without you and
if you'd like to support the channel
consider becoming a member on patreon or
grabbing something from the Wi-Fi store
after this episode we're gonna need to
sell white files diapers really too much
too much that's gonna do it until next
time be safe be kind and know that you
are appreciated did you hear my elbow
hit that thing God damn it
[Music]
thank you